in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I help some sports fans fix their
caching performance while we hit a
performance buzzer beater stay tuned to
find out
geeky sports is a website devoted to the
latest and greatest regarding your
favorite sci-fi fantasy based sports yes
they even have coverage of that
wizard-based broomstick soccer game with
the flying locust thing that people try
to catch anyhow their engineering team
reached out after they deployed a new
CDN and thumbnailing service only to see
a massive Cashville cost show up on
their cloud bill yet no performance
improvements showing up for their
customers now this all sounds like the
right setup so let's try to figure out
what's going on firstly to check that
the assets were actually being cashed we
took a look at the logging information
for the load balancer in the cloud
console each request that slog will have
information detailing if it properly had
a cache hit or not for example we can
see that the first request resulted in a
lookup a failure and a fill meanwhile
our second request to the same resource
results in just a cache hit looking back
at the logs for geeky sports we can see
that the number of cache hit entries is
really low for their traffic during the
day so it seems the requests were
getting cached but not being reused by
future requests hence the high cache
fill bill now let's think about this for
a second at their core CDNs are really
just massively distributed hash tables
when a request comes in to the CDN it
converts the URI of that request to a
cache key if that key matches anything
that's already been cached then it just
returns the Associated object now by
default Google Cloud CDN uses the
complete request URI as the cache key
which means if you change the protocol
like moving from HTTP to HTTPS you're
not going to get a cache hit and
likewise if the query string is
different you won't get a match either
and that last one seems to be the
important one looking back at the logged
requests geeky sports is passing the
user token as a URL parameter was
causing each asset to be cached by the
CDN individually rather than being
shared between users thankfully for our
geeky friends the fix is pretty
straightforward using Google Cloud CDNs
custom cache keys we can modify how the
CDN matches you
our eyes for specific assets and tell it
to ignore the query string looking at
the logs we can see that even though the
user ID is different we got a proper hit
on the asset to learn more about how
geeky sports decrease to their costs
check out the Related article linked in
the description below and don't forget
to check out the rest of our cloud
performance Atlas content because when
it comes to performance every
millisecond counts